hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar learn how to maximize kingfisher
instruments to automate dna rna proteins
and cells for all applications i am
marie stone of labrutz and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
dr saraj patel
emea sample preparation business manager
thermo fisher scientific
emily zehringer r d staff scientist
sample preparation biosciences thermo
fisher scientific usa
and dr kettle peterson manager and staff
scientist thermo fisher scientific
welcome you may now begin your
presentations
thank you marie
okay so thank you very much for your
time today so the agenda for this
meeting is going to be uh we're going to
first focus on methods for sample
purification then we're going to focus
on benefits of automated workflows uh
going to go into the size cost 2
isolation and beyond and then moving
into transitioning between these
applications and then there's obviously
a q a session at the end
so we're gonna we're gonna talk about
methods for sample purification and as
uh you saw at the beginning this was
focused on the kingfisher
instrumentation so the story kind of
begins with nucleic acid extraction
so this next slide just shows you um
three
common types of nucleic acid extractions
that customers will normally do you've
got spin columns organic extraction such
as trisol or phenol and then you've got
automated systems as well because there
are other ones out there on the market
so this just kind of points out the
challenges that people tend to face with
these instruments with these systems so
with the spin column just to highlight a
few it's very labor intensive and quite
time consuming with organic extraction
consistency can be a problem and working
with difficult um toxic agents and then
with automated systems you tend to be
locked into the protocol that the
instrument gives you right or
consumables such as cassettes and things
like that so you don't get much
flexibility uh for your sample type or
your protocol
so what what we wanted to do at
thermofish is we wanted to create a
solution
for some of these pain points which
involves magnetic beads and automation
so believe it or not this solution has
been around for 22 years and that's the
kingfisher product line
and you can see here a timeline that
we've put up of when the first
kingfisher was introduced in 1999
and then subsequently other instruments
after that i just want to focus on
the kingfisher flex in the middle of
your screen the kingfisher duo prime and
the presto they're the current three
instruments out on the market uh which
are the most popular and then just
recently this year we've launched the
kingfisher apex in 2021 and uh that's
already doing really well and is a big
upgrade to the um for how the system
move are going to be moving forward so
today we've got 17 000 instruments out
in the field and just at the bottom
there you can see in terms of our
applications one of the biggest ones we
were thrown into was the solid cop2
testing uh because of the fact that we
can do rna extractions on our systems
so just to give you a little insight
into how the kingfishers
work it works on two main plate formats
the first is a 96 deep well and it has a
working volume which must include your
sample your buffer your beads everything
from 13 microliters up to one mil so
this is mainly designed for high
throughput extraction
we've got another plate format which is
the 24 well plate and that allows you to
have a higher volume so you're going to
work from 0.2 mil up to 5 mil
so this is really good for the higher
volume work but you do compromise on
throughput because we can only do 24
samples at a time to put it into some
kind of real perspective if you were
extracting dna from blood the first 96
well plate would be for 50 microliters
of whole blood to 400 microliters of
whole blood and then if you want to go
up to say one mil to
five mil then you'd be using the 24 watt
plate so that's kind of how that works
there are different uh heads available
so we talked about the 24 and the 96
there's also a smaller 96 volt head for
low volume and there's also another 96
volt head
for pcr plates so we can use them on the
system as well
just to go into a little bit more detail
about the individual systems and how
they compare to each other i'm not going
to go through the whole slide but i will
highlight that the duo prime is focused
on that compact bench top instrument
right so for low to medium throughput
and when you're working on a 96 wall
plate they extract 12 samples at a time
when you go to the 24 you're extracting
six samples at a time and um and this is
really good for research use only um
when you when you want that next step up
in throughput you've got the flex so
this is more the medium to the high
throughput and you can see the samples
per run it operates on the whole 96 well
plate at a time
or a whole 24-hour plate so you can get
much higher throughput in your
extractions um and then you've got and
both of these instruments work on the
binding software which is a separate
software that comes and allows you to
actually change and optimize your
protocols if you wish
i'll come back to the apex the press
the presto is another version of
the
system but this is made for liquid
handling instruments so if you want a
complete automation solution where
you're not
putting any samples or liquids into the
plates yourself but you want a liquid a
robot liquid handler to do that you
bring in the presto and that will do all
of that for you and again it works on 96
and 24. so the apex is kind of an
advancement on the flanks
and um you get some extra features such
as being able to have two heads on the
machine uv light and also a cooling
function the rest of them have heating
but the apex has a nice cooling function
for certain applications
so we did a survey and looked at our
customers and tried to narrow down what
our customers are using the instruments
for most of them are for infectious
disease testing and kind of i guess a
lot of that falls into coving um kobe
testing but then we've also got others
for virology oncology sexual health and
also other applications such as
bacterial detection and genomic dna and
rna extraction is quite popular as well
so i want to talk about the workflow and
i want to kind of just introduce how we
create this high throughput automatable
workflow with the kingfisher and using
our dyna beads
so the next slide just focuses on those
key points so we with our with our
combination of the instrument and the
beads we get better increased
sensitivity better significant time
savings because it's automated and you
don't need to be using at the bench and
then increase productivity
and then here you can see that using the
dyna beads
when you're using in a manual situation
or with a magnet your liquid handling so
if you're familiar with dyna beads
you're introducing your beads they bind
the target you're then
holding the beads washing them and then
finally removing your
target out in solution while holding the
beak the way the kingfisher works it
turns out on its head what if you could
pick up the bee
so with the kingfisher you load the
plate so each plate becomes a step in
the process you load the plates onto the
machine the machine will mix the plates
pick up the beads and move them from one
step to another and eventually in your
elution plate it will elute your target
off the bead
pick up and remove those beads leaving
your target behind on in the addition
plate so that's essentially how the
kingfisher works and in this case of the
apex you've got a turntable for each of
your plates
okay so let's take that to our most
popular um application which is fast
cop2 so this just really quickly shows
you the thermofisher workflow for sales
cop2 and obviously you've got we've got
products for receiving samples real-time
pcr and analysis but we're focusing on
the middle part which is preparing
samples
and this is a slide that just shows you
our workflow with our mvp2 kit and you
can see starting from the left whether
you've got an inactivated sample or a
live sample we've got protocols for both
we can inactivate with our binding
buffer and then go straight into our
extraction so that works really well and
that extraction is performed in 22
minutes
so what i want to kind of really focus
on on this presentation is
going beyond fast cough 2. if you've
already got the instrument and you're
already doing side crop 2 extractions
what more can you do with this system
that's kind of what i really want to
focus on
and this slide just looks at it because
i want you to think about it in two ways
one from the sample perspective and one
from an application perspective so
currently if you're using it for sales
cop2 you're going to be using a nasal
pharyngeal swap so that is one kind of
method that you can use but we've
actually got protocols for the mvp2 kit
for different types of samples so whole
blood saliva plasma serum
all of these can be used on the same
system that you're already using and be
able to extract and then there's we can
actually go beyond that we can actually
go to different other types of sources
so you can see animal health plant and
soil and food safety and then we can
also do other targets such as cells
stool samples even ffp
samples so we've got kits within
thermofisher that can do that
but the key thing to understand from a
sample perspective you can go way beyond
what you're currently using it for even
to those far fringes of plant and animal
health samples
to take that another step further like i
mentioned is thinking about it from
applications point of view so we're
currently doing viral testing at the
moment from the saskatchewan but you can
also use it um you can see on this deck
from the left hand side is focused on
nucleic acids so you can see we've got
beads and kits for pcr cleanup high
molecular weight and then other types of
rna extractions as well but we've also
got beads for protein isolation so you
can do luminex immunoprecipitation
smart digest which is a trypsin digest
and we can also do cell isolations as
well
we can also work with custom beads
because you can change the protocol to
what you need it to be
and it all all of these applications are
ready for downstream uh such as digital
pcr ngs chromatography um so you can see
from this slide and the previous one the
system opens up a lot more sample prep
than where you started with and
hopefully new things that you can think
about doing with your system
this slide just shows you various kits
that we have so we have various kits to
go for dna rna total nucleic acid
proteins and cells
and then i kind of want to talk about
that next step beyond that so we were
looking at starscoff ii from
laserfrontial swabs but we've also done
a lot of work with customers on
wastewater samples so these next few
slides just talk about the importance of
wastewater so the idea is to use
wastewater surveillance testing and and
it can be for various uh targets polio
is quite one that's quite common but we
were focusing on saskatchewan and
basically allowing customers to use our
workflow in in testing the wastewater so
we've got two types of protocols i
wanted to highlight and they're using
our wastewater
nucleic acid enrichment kit
which is highlighted here
and the first protocol focuses on one
mil of your wastewater sample directly
into our kit so you just take one mil go
straight into our kit and do the
extraction and you can get some
quantification but then we we and we've
got some data here showing you that as
well so you can see that we spiked in
some controls and did some um
quantification with qpcr on that and
then the next step is a protocol that's
again using the kingfisher but we're
using a viral concentration with
magnetic beads and using a much higher
input of 10 mil so you can see from the
next slide the data showing that we're
getting consistent extraction um and
good ct values for false cop2 in 10 mils
of wastewater so if you were interested
in doing that that's another thing you
could do with our kingfisher but like i
said we can go beyond that so i just
wanted to highlight one of those
applications which is oncology and um i
wanted to focus on detection of cell
free dna
so this is um cell free dna is something
that oncology uh researchers are looking
at and you we're looking at that because
in oncology we want to be able to take a
kind of liquid biopsy um from a cust
from a patient and that is what we're
kind of focusing on here so we're taking
a blood sample and we're trying to see
if we can look at the cell free dna
coming from the tumor and be able to
diagnose or do some therapeutic
treatment with those customers uh a
patient sorry so the next slide here um
is
excuse me so the um the next slide here
is showing the selfie dna kit that we
use for this
um and and this kit will be used for
isolation of selfie dna from serum
plasma or urine and the key thing to
understand uh when you look at the
traces if you do a quant if you do a
quantification which is concentration
it'll end up quite low to what you'd be
expecting but that's because our purity
is much higher when you run it on a
buyer analyzer you can see that our
selfie dna peak is much more
concentrated compared to the genomic dna
which is decreased so this is something
that's quite normal with our kit so our
purity is much higher and then this is
just showing you some digital pcr data
where they were comparing
the
extraction from sfp samples and also
liquid biopsy to see if there's any
differences in the genetic profile and
then finally
for taking it that step further as well
as selfie dna some people are looking at
circulating tumor cells and i know this
can be quite difficult to isolate so
there's a publication uh which we worked
with a customer rui in dusseldorf and
this and what we were doing is trying to
see can we isolate circulating tumor
cells from using the kingfisher and some
targeted bees and you can see from this
data here i'm just showing it worked
really well
not only did we isolate we fixed and
stained the cells as well
so it's worth looking at that paper okay
so hopefully hand over to emily for this
part
yes thank you siraj um
so and thank you to our listeners um
again for coming into the webinar
so i'll be taking over and covering
another application
switching gears a little bit to genetic
testing
genetic testing of course focusing on
dna extraction
with the
downstream application
examples of genotyping and also
exo exome sequencing workflows
and so traditionally
genetic testing has been performed with
whole blood and buckle swab samples
however
in recent years saliva has really
emerged as a popular collection method
and for several reasons one it's very
automation
and high throughput friendly being a
liquid sample it's also a much simpler
collection method saliva um is often
self-collected
um and there's two ways really you can
collect it either as a raw uh saliva
sample
into a tube or um collecting into a
stabilization reagent uh which preserves
the nucleic acid in the sample and
allows you to store it
um
both for longer and to store um at
ambient temperatures
so in addition to simple collection uh
salivas also
fits very nicely into an automated
workflow the collection tubes are
barcoded and in standardized sizes and
so function in liquid handling as well
as cappers and decappers
they also allow quick delivery results
being a
easily accessible and easily processed
sample
in addition to these benefits which are
very useful for genetic testing they
also have a benefit which has become of
interest to pathogen detection is that
it's
low cost but also the especially the
stabilized saliva
provides some viral inactivation
allowing the samples to be processed
outside of
highly
you know bsl3 or bsl2
labs
so
you know it makes saliva a nice sample
and kind of unique and then it covers
all this compared to buckle swabs and
whole blood
um and we actually do have um
for both the raw and the stabilized
saliva
our specie max
devices provide an option for this
so if you have questions about that
please be sure to
ask in the q a
so as i said saliva has become a
great interest kind of an emerging
sample type people would like to use
but
when using a new sample type you of
course want to make sure that it
compares well back to the you know
original ones and make sure that they
match in concordance and performance
um
and so here we actually used our
magmaxine multi-sample ultra 2.0 kit
combined with kingfisher flex in order
to conduct a concordance study and here
we compared whole blood buckle swab and
saliva
um three sample types from donors they
were matched samples
and to the right you can see as far as
for each sample type kind of their um
you know from i guess decreasing um you
know
discomfort whole blood of course is the
most evasive buccal swabs um fairly
simple some are in the middle and of
course saliva
really doesn't get much easier than
sitting in a tube
but so anyway we collected these three
match sample types from 25 donors
ranging in ages
and then performed
our extraction workflow analysis both
for qpcr um for genotyping as well as
sequencing
and so here you can see
we performed the genomic dna extractions
using our ultra 2.0 kit and our
kingfisher flex
then quantified and checked quality of
the dna using the nano drop and the
qubit
instruments and kits
and then looked at two different types
of downstream analysis we first
looked at sequencing using the
amplifique exome kit
and then we also looked at real-time pcr
with several of the taqman genotyping
assays
and so we performed this for
all donors and then for all of the
sample types for each donor um
there we go
so here you can see kind of a
of the results
the top graph is showing the genotyping
percent call rates
for both the heterozygous and both
homozygous alleles
for the three sample types
for all different donors and these are
just
targeting three specific
genes or snips excuse me
you know and as you can see the call
rate is equivalent almost identical for
all three sample types between the
different donors so showing very good
concordance for genotyping
the same if you look at the bottom graph
variant calling concordance
you can see it's all in red and the red
indicates the variance the same in all
samples for all sample types
so
very good results indicating all three
sample types
provides the proper results
needed
and then here kind of looking at the
overall
variant calling concordance between the
sample types and between all the
different donors you can see
uh between 22 donors we have a 94
match variant call rate
between the buckle slots and saliva and
then greater than 93
for the whole blood
um
to saliva and then whole blood to buccal
swabs
and so um based on the study indicating
a very high concordance between the
different sample types between the match
sample types between the different
donors
um
you know indicating that saliva
in addition to having good benefits also
will work in the workflow and so um
study was beneficial twofold one to show
that saliva um is a very useful sample
type and two to show another way you can
use the kingfisher flex instrument
um
you know and then of course just a few
details about the ultra 2.0 kit very
versatile like the flex instrument
you know it allows both low sample
inputs up to high sample inputs i'm
using both the 96 and 24 wall formats
and is compatible um with the other
kingfisher instruments in addition to
the flex
so as suraj mentioned
the flex allows you
to
you can use a flex from multiple
different research applications
everything from
stars kobe 2 which
suraj gave a nice summary on
to looking at different bacteria
also looking at kind of more specific
research areas sexual health
women's health and healthcare-associated
infections
and so actually the next section and
talk about one of these areas looking at
vaginal and urinary microbiota um
with the flex and magmest kits as part
of the workflow
and so um yeah so specifically looking
at detection of vaginal urinary tract
microbiota the first question is kind of
why
um you know would you want to look into
this area why is this important for
research and just kind of interesting
facts
your adrenaline infections affects
greater than one billion women each year
and of these infections
some are associated with additional
types of infections like cervicitis and
pelvic infections
um and so if you're looking more
specifically at bacterial vaginosis it
affects 10 to 15 percent of women
reproductive age and of course this kind
of converts into a huge cost
because it can cause pregnancy
complications
um you know and so it's just kind of a
it's
something you wish to avoid if possible
and so you know by doing research and
being able to detect pathogens specific
to this um to understand
can be very beneficial to a large number
of women
and so um traditionally
for detection of these types of
pathogens uh culture-based detection
methods were used and although they work
very well they have some drawbacks such
as lack of sensitivity um they can be
subjective and often require very
lengthy turnaround time
as an alternative in i guess the past
decade or so
they've started to transition to
molecular methods
which
have really reduced turnaround time and
increased sensitivity and specificity
for being able to
detect
specific pathogens
and so um excuse me
just to give you more of a graphical
representation you know between the
traditional workflow and then the
molecular workflow so here you can see
traditional of you two different sample
types you have your purification with
nucleic acid or protein or just
um
[Music]
you know purifying the different cells
you know separate for each sample and
then what type of sample are you looking
for
and then you know what type of test and
so you can see it can grow exponentially
and kind of a reason why sometimes these
results can take
uh quite a long time
alternatively we have
the molecular workflow which similar
workflow but simplifies it immensely so
you know most of these have been
converted into high throughput even
automated and so you have multiple
samples one method one
downstream output
um
so simple comprehensive and allows for
targeted analysis
so you're able to get your sample to
results much more manageable amount of
time sometimes even within a day
so
so as part of the workflow for
these molecular methods one point of one
part of course is the sample preparation
nucleic acid and so
we do have a magmax kit
specific for that the magmax viral
pathogen ultra kit
very similar to our magma spiral
pathogen kit
except it has an additional enzymatic
digestion to help life the
gram-positive bacteria as well as yeast
and fungi
like most of our magmax kip's very
flexible it has a to a low input and a
high input
either with the 96 well or 24-well
format
allows you to elute in a low volume
as well as use
a multitude of different liquid samples
it's also compatible
with all of our kingfisher instruments
although we will focus on the following
slides on its use with the flex
instruments in this detection workflow
and so here you can see um kind of how
it fits in so you have your different
sample types
and for you know vaginal microbiota of
course thin prep
e-swab
are going to be your focus for things
like the urinary tax the urine of course
even stabilized urine
so then these samples will be extracted
with the magmax viral pathogen ultra kit
on the kingfish reflex um and so what it
will
um allow is recovery of both rna and dna
in your illusion um including
bacteria yeast virus and protozoa and
then once you have this nucleic acid
then you can move on into our various
taqman pcr
panels and these include up to the most
high throughput which is the open array
to more low throughput which will be our
singleplex tacman panels
kind of define those a little bit better
you can see you know from low throughput
all the way to the highest throughput
um
all of these are very um they have good
sensitivity and specificity it just
really depends you know if you have
if you want to maximize um you know the
information you get or if you only need
certain information so um
but the benefit of this workflow um it
provides you and so here you can see we
have several app notes focused around
this so looking at the vaginal
microbiota you know again here's the
workflow looking specifically with the
open array
and so it's targeting these bacteria
in a various number of formats and it
provides you just a large amount of data
and so here you can see if you kind of
break it out into specific research um
groups you can see here's bacterial
vaginosis and looking at
you know
to 96 samples you can see it
gives you the the ct values which thing
can be kind of worked with to find a
pattern or to find you know a specific
detection
target for example you know imhominus
same thing if you're looking at you know
here specifically aerobic vaginitis for
these targets
and then again looking more at
candida species
for yeast
and then of course sti if you're looking
more for those so it provides so much
flexibility
and i think the final one is just the
commensal lactobacilli
within the sample so
a huge amount of information for
relatively a small amount of effort
similar we have for the urinary
microbiota
you know again same workflow just with
urine samples different targets um again
we have an app note around this um but
here you can see we actually looked at
results with the open array with our
taqman which you'll see in blue and then
results generate positive results
generated by culture and you can see
again you know the increase in
sensitivity
and detection for the pcr
versus the culture
and then finally
um here we're actually looking again
um different targets
you know with culture versus the
open array results
and you can see
again how it compares against the
culture so
equivalent or more sensitive
results
and so with that i will
pass it on to kethel
who will cover
more of the protein applications um
you can perform with the instrument
thanks emily
so that brings me to the
the final part of this this training
that we will address or talk a little
bit about protein application and put an
application on the kingfisher
kingfisher instrument
so
i would like to talk a little bit about
immunoprecipitation and this is a method
that are commonly used in many many
different research fields like
immunology basic cancer research
etc which you would like to pull out
the protein of interest or proteins
uh
that will bind to each other so that you
you're studying protein protein
interaction and these interactions are
all
quite often quite weak and transient in
drug interactions and in such a workflow
then you use typically use a an antibody
that will bind your protein of interest
or the proteins that you would like to
to use to study protein protein
interactions
and then these antibodies that are
are
conjugated to a solid surface whether
it's a non-magnetic or a magnetic uh
bead
surface
the magnetic magnetic beads being these
dynamics that we have been working
a lot with
and the downstream and to use it uh in
in downstream applications such as
western blotting or also mass spectrum
spectrometry
the workflow itself includes many
different steps
it's here we have illustrated the direct
approach
where you
first functionalize your beads in this
case it's the magnetic dynamics so your
functionalized beads with antibodies and
this is
due to the built-in advantages of the
dynamics they
binding on these antibodies to the bs
are super fast so that can be done in in
like 10 minutes
and then you follow this with a washing
step where you remove
unbound antibodies
from the bead surface so you're sitting
there with with antibodies that are
conjugated
non-covalently to to the beads before
you then transfer these functionalized
speeds to a biological sample to pull
out your protein of interest or protein
complexes
but then this is then followed by
washing steps to to remove
unwanted
complexes
and then finally you
you elude off your target of interest or
protein complex of interest for
downstream
analysis
at one point we reached out to a number
of researchers out there that are using
this workflow and ask them what kind of
pain points do they actually have with
this workflow and how could we assist
them in making this
this workflow even easier and better
and then the response from all these
researchers were
where that this is a manual method
mistakes happens
but we would like to reduce the number
of errors that we do in
our basic research just in order for us
to make all the experiments that we do
count so we don't do
so that we do less
mistakes
but we also would like to to increase
the
reproducibility so that we
compare can compare our experiments
better
but very interestingly they also would
like to have solutions that allow them
to
to spend their time more wisely
so
avoiding spending a huge amount of time
in the lab doing pipetting but more
focusing on on the science
that's of course a scientist's interest
so they would like to have hands-off
solutions
um and
the the solution
is of course in the combination of the
diabetes the magnetic dynamics
functionalized for pulling out target
proteins and the kingfisher instrument
which is uh sir george mentioned
a brilliant instrument moving beets
instead of liquid
so this makes
the perfect match to to both
reduce error rate increase
reproducibility but
also
to
focus your workload in the lab by
by
all the samples in your plates
and then just push the button and walk
away
and then just come back when you
when when when the
the protocol is is done and the the
proteins that we have captured already
for analysis
of course we could have done this
very very quick
we should have
just transferred this manual protocol
that we have developed over many years
and just write a script on the in the
binded software for for the kingfisher
instrument it's
the software in on this instrument is
very intuitive so you will be able to
write this script within a few minutes
but we would like to take deep dives
into
this script that we have on the key now
have on the kingfisher instrument and
just to make sure that the performance
of this script is as good or even better
than the manual protocol that we already
have
so we developed an essay
based upon accredited acridinium
orange
that was
conjugated to antibodies and then we
followed this labeled antibody
throughout the whole protocol
so we mesh we conjugated antibodies that
were labeled with that
acrylic orange on the surface of the
dynabits and then measured the signal on
the beads the signal that we were able
to obtain in the washing buffer
and also in the illusion or in the
elliott
just to see
the face of
this antibody because if we do lose them
throughout the protocol then we will
also lose the target
and in order to optimize and fine-tune
this script
we
took a look at different
different parameters
in this workflow
to see just to see whether which of them
were critical and which were not
critical and we looked at
at parameters like temperature
target volume incubation time washing
steps and volumes but also
the illusion volume and mixing
conditions
and the result of these
all these experiments and we did quite a
lot of them
we ended up with three critical factors
for a successful
immunoprecipitation on the kingfisher
instrument
and those the two of them were related
to washing
so by having many washing steps and also
with a more rough mixing conditions
you may run the risk of losing
your target and the antibody from the
bead surface so then the yield will be
reduced so that's why we
included more very gentle mixing
throughout the washing steps in this in
this workflow on the kingfisher
in terms of dilution
here we saw the opposite so by
increasing
the elusion volume then you increase the
yield so we tested
in the rain in the range of 30
microliters up to 100 microliters of the
aleutian
elusion buffer
so the the final slides i would just
like to
highlight a few data sets where we
compared
uh the automated
uh workflow that the ones that we have
just optimized testing all these
different
parameters
ending up with three critical ones
so here we have functionalized dynamics
with antibodies and then exposed them to
cell lysates
and then we have looks at all proteins
that have been bound to these speeds
which we can then elute off
by using low ph like a gentle evolution
method or more rough elusion using lds
at 70 degrees celsius
then we have stained them
using silver staining
so here we can see that
whether we use low ph as an allusion
method or lds as an additional method we
see comparable
proteins bound and diluted off
the dynabits whether we use a manual or
an automated
workflow so these two methods are
equally
good
in terms of of background or on specific
specific binding
but of course
the most important part is of course the
[Music]
is of course the yield
so we have then also performed the same
the same experiment
but then we instead of doing
cellular staining to
sustain all
the
[Music]
the proteins that are on the gel we
continue to do western blotting
to detect
specific proteins that we have captured
in this case we have captured
the tetraspan in protein cd9
either
dinobits protein g or adinab that have
been conjugated with secondary
antibodies
and then
functionalized with anti-cd9 antibodies
and also here in terms of the bands we
can see that the
the um the yield
of the cd9
is equally as good
with automated
versus versus manual so in terms of the
performance here on the immune
precipitation
the automated protocol is at least as
good as the manual protocol
but also the benefit here is that you
can actually just push the button
and walk away and do something more
scientifically interesting than to to do
pipetting
so the final slide here
um i would just like to
conclude this session by
by showing
the new kingfisher apex
instrument which is a really really nice
instrument that have of course all the
benefits that are included in the
kingfisher flex instrument but also
added new features such as uv
uv light it's got
bar coding so you can scan
the barcodes on the plates
it's also a cloud-based system it's got
a very intuitive
touch screen that you can actually
play around with the protocol if you
need to do that
on this on this screen
but as we are working in my group we are
working with cells we are working with
exosomes
with
virus
source code two wires we are working
also on proteins
i really like to
i'm very happy to see that that this
instrument has got also got
cooling
which is very beneficial when you do
cell isolation on this instrument
and with this i would like to thank you
thank you siraj emily and kettle for
your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
if i wanted to switch between
applications such as moving from dna
extraction to protein isolation is this
a difficult process
hello can i answer this
sure
yeah thank you okay so um it's it's
actually really simple so if you're
doing any type of dna extraction and
you're using our kit you would be
familiar already with the software and
how it all works in loading the plate so
if you move to a protein isolation the
only thing you need to do is selected
the right type of bead um so kettle
talked about some immunoprecipitation
protocols and then some of the beads
that we'd be using for that so the
really nice thing is if it's the
thermofish a bead set there should be
some protocols already written for the
kingfisher so depending on the
instrument that you have uh the flex or
the duo prime you can just download them
from the website and then start using
them straight away if you have the apex
which is cloud connected you have access
to them straight away so it's actually
really simple and the process would be
the same loading the plate adding them
onto the machine and moving it through
and it and it's the same for any of the
applications
if the thermofisher kit we should have
protocols already and if not we've got a
whole team of specialists that can
support you in making sure that you get
the right protocol and hopefully off to
help you optimize the protocol as well
thank you
our next question
you mentioned saliva do you have a
recommended collection storage method
for this sample type to best preserve
all nucleic acids or cells present
i can take this one
okay great
um so
it really does depend kind of on your
downstream application there's a
multitude available
as i mentioned there's both raw
collection and stabilized collection
we do have a line of saliva collection
device devices recently released this is
our speciemax devices and we offer both
a raw version and a stabilized version
which um is what i would recommend
great thank you
our next question is
can you put the apex slide up again it
was only up for a second on my end
see i think um if
one of the presenters would like to
go back to the slide with the
apex
great thank you
so then our next question is
what is the full workflow time hands on
an
for both the vaginal and urinary tract
workflows
i can take this one great
um for the full workflow from
once you have the sample tool you're
able to get results of the instrument
is eight hours or less
right great
thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
who should i contact to determine if a
process i'm currently running could be
adapted to run on the kingfisher system
and to identify which would be best to
try
um so i can answer that
um you would need to contact
one of our tss teams
because you're trying to adapt one of
your current protocols right so that
that would need a bit more of a
technical conversation um i don't know
if we're able to get the details of this
customer and then i can make sure that
someone gets in touch is that possible
yeah okay so so if i could get the
customer details and if possible if you
could let me know where you're based
because it depends on the right
person we get to you but just getting
your contact details is enough and we'll
get someone to contact you directly
about it
great
well thank you siraj emily and kettle do
you have any final comments for our
audience
all right
oh sorry siraj did you have it thank you
very much for your time we really
appreciate it and any support you need
moving your kingfishers onto different
applications we're here to help
great well thank you again siraj emily
and kettle for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye